so i thought today in honor of uh flora
and ulysses
on disney plus yeah i would help you i
would help you
figure out ways to craft with food for
your kids which is so much fun
so i thought we'd make this little
squirrel
snack not for swirls but it's shaped
like a squirrel
well teach me teach me where do we start
so i can be like you
and my girls would love we baked so much
i've made every muffin and cake and
bread on the planet
this is so much more inventive teach me
yes okay so let's start with the
squirrel you uh you'll take two breaks
um i sort of go for the big one and then
like a little one that's gonna be the
head
um and then you just poke a toothpick
through the bottom
of the big the big thing obviously
you'll tell your kids there's a
toothpick in it so they don't just
bite into it um and then leave a little
nubbin
out because that will help you stand it
up later
exactly and then um
you should have some mini chocolate
chips
the ears so that'll be ears so
chocolate icing for a little glue
so you just dab a little um you know
chocolate icing and then put the ear
i've got food tweezers because i'm
obsessed
um put it sort of back on the top of the
little grape but sort of on the top
um and then the next one kind of close
to that one because
i feel like squirrel ears are close
together okay so then i think next we
should move on to the little
candy eyes do you have those i do
i do because i get obsessed like i said
i use
white icing for this oh
you know what that makes total sense
that's fine just do the chocolate it
doesn't matter um so now put those not
actually that far away from the ears
because
um i've tried them on the side and they
looked it looked like a
possessed squirrel oh yours is so good
okay great
so now i also liked uh using a mini
chocolate chip is the nose
okay and so then you take the bigger
chocolate chips not the the
giant one and make little arms pink
on the side and then i do two
uh in the front of the big grape uh as
legs i really feel the facial expression
that i've
talked about it's all about the eyes i'm
very endeared these eyes
are amazing where do you procure food
eyes
i mean everywhere michael's sells a
bunch of them
oh yeah on amazon he's like
he looks like he's on johnny carson
right now no i love him
sort of set that down okay and put him
aside for a second
so so you'll take your little um
it's like a ho ho or a ding dong i don't
know what it is but i want it so badly
so in the south um i grew up with this
brand because uh
because i'm from atlanta but you just
cut one of these in half or in thirds
and then you'll have two and then i
will put icing in the middle of them
um to glue these two together this is
going to represent the little log that
the
squirrel is going to sit on but it needs
wide so that
um so the tail will fit
and then you can stick uh your little
uh squirrel without the tail into the
like
one side of it okay
two logs uh oh
oh yeah sitting on a log
he's gonna fit on a log and the second
log is gonna help hold his tail in place
because his tail is quite heavy
okay so now do you have the pre-made um
cereal treat
the marshmallow cereal treats i do right
here
so the best way that i've found is to
stick a toothpick into what will touch
the squirrel's body the so sort of the
yes and then i also just for security
um do some more chocolate icing because
who doesn't like chocolate frosting
what i mean i just want to put my face
in all of this is that wrong
and then you just put that
into your little squirrel i forgot to um
shorten my toothpick so
he's being impaled um so normally
i would cut that with a scissor and then
even easier take your big
chocolate chip and your little small
cookie and then just dab a little
chocolate on the thing on the either one
and then press it down and put a little
mini chocolate chip on top
and ta-da you have
an acorn
and then to be healthy i added a
strawberry mushroom on top of a
you know because my grape and
strawberries it's a healthy treat right
this is so awesome allison i love this
oh wow
i love it i think your kid's gonna be
really happy i am definitely gonna go
home and do this with them tonight
so thank you for that i'm also um going
to have them watch
flora and ulysses with me tonight
because i got to watch it this weekend
um for research and
it really kind of like circles back to
our original conversation which is
when are you a grown-up when are you a
kid like
all of these little messages that we're
supposed to grow up and flourish with as
human beings
um i just remember i loved so much
with this story too of like we have to
have hope
and sort of in the darkest times of our
lives that's when you knitted the most
and it's also
the hardest to find so so that really
resonated with me as well
i just think this is a perfect movie for
a family too because
the kids are going to love it the adults
are going to love it and that's what we
need right now
more time together on the couch
definitely
snacks be sure to watch flora and
ulysses
with your family it's available now on
disney plus